bonsoir à vous merci à d'être avec nous
génération identitaire à ce que c'est un
groupuscule un groupe dangereux pour la
société
c'est politiquement la fraction jeunes
d'une formation d'extrême droite qui
s'appelle identitaire avec des huiles
étant peu nombreux et c'est sa fraction
jeunes qui a fait commettre cette
sensibilité politique au travers de type
d'action reprenant type d'action plutôt
à gauche voir avec ce trend gauche
c'est-à-dire des actions très symbolique
c'est à dire on joue l'opinion publique
au travers de symbole d' images fortes
relayé par les médias et réseaux sociaux
et chaînes d'information en continu et
donc du coup il s'agit d'une bataille
idéologique pour gagner l'hégémonie
culturelle et politique sur des thèmes
si clairement la question de
l'immigration
donc les actions sont menées de sorte
d'essayer de ne pas encourir justement
ce qui maintenant est reproché par le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est-à-dire
deux types d'accusations contre
génération identitaire l'atteinte à
l'ordre public et incitation à la
discrimination et la haine raciale
on va voir ce que dit ce que disent
elles les juges car nous sommes dans un
état de droit mais on voit bien au fond
le type de bataille sur un sujet qui va
être au fond très présent d'ordre lors
de la prochaine présidentielle est
l'intérêt de ce moment c'est pas
seulement la question autour de ce
groupe de ce qu'il va advenir mais aussi
de voir comment les uns et les autres se
positionne sur cette question notamment
à la droite de la droite voire d'extrême
droite et les menaces de dissolution qui
pèsent sur un génération identitaire
l'entée dont gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur oui absolument alors le
ministre de l'intérieur et la majorité
actuelle des seuils dans le moment
actuel de donner le sentiment de faire
une balance égale entre des dissolutions
de formation islamiste comme le ccf et
baraka city repérée depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs en la matière et puis un
groupe assez restreint
quelle génération identitaire mais qui a
mené des actions qui semblait pointer
les lacunes de d'état en matière de
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
et c'est là où au fond ce groupe
d'extrême droite rencontre l'opinion
dans la mesure où les français dans les
études d'opinion sont favorables à
l'asile politique c'est la tradition
française des droits de l'homme donc une
majorité de français sont absolument
favorable à l'asile politique par contre
ils sont opposés de phase iii ces
importantes à l'immigration économique
donc l'émigration clandestine
surtout si l'asile politique semble être
un prétexte pour une immigration
économique au fond rencontre une
opposition d'une majorité de français
dans laquelle est celle de son groupe
ferait ce groupe d'extrême droite qui
lui a tendance à faire un amalgame au
fond lorsque j'entendais la france aux
français ce t1 vingtaine de ma jeunesse
dans un et soixante dix groupes occident
pierre sidos donc lequel il amalgame au
fond on ne voit bien c'est l'immigration
clandestine musulmans islam islamisme
boire terrorisme alors ça c'est pour ce
groupe d'extrême droite c'est pas pour
tout l'extrême droite la droite de la
droite qui
pourrait soutenir génération identitaire
mais quand même
yasmine arrière fond en terme de
bataille d'hégémonie politique et
culturelle de ce groupe d'extrême droite
qui a su trouver des formes de
mobilisation assez habile au fond pour
rencontrer ben l'attention du public et
les médias font état général c'est un
handicap divise la classe politique
divise l'opinion publique on l'a vu
encore aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya une
contre manifestation
ddd antifa quelle est votre lecture
parce qu'il s'est passé aujourd'hui bon
écoutez là à l'extrême droite répond
ultragauche connu historique crois qu'il
faut pas accorder énormément
d'importance ni d'un côté ni de l'autre
la nouveauté c'est les modalités
d'intervention des générations
identitaire c'est la volonté du ministre
de l'intérieur de dissoudre ce groupe on
va voir si les arguments juridiques sont
suffisants il ya beaucoup de je dirais
de critiques c'est sympa pas être
évident pour le juge forcément de statut
et on la matière le ya toujours eu dans
notre pays des groupes anti fasciste
soit de nature anarchiste soit de nature
trotskiste soit de nature autonome et il
y a toujours eu face à l'extrême droite
dite fasciste face à des anti fascisme
nos membres de l'extrême gauche ou du
courant anarchiste
merci beaucoup à vous pour cette analyse
stéphane rozès je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue enseignant à hec et
sciences-po fin